Olá meus queridos minhas queridas vamos
para as perguntas de vocês e depois
vamos discutir um assunto bem
interessante que foi tema da palestra do
José nass no Congresso médicos pela vida
primeira coisa eu queria o feedback de
vocês do áudio porque eu tô testando uma
configuração nova agora o microfone tá
ligado ao iPhone o iPhone está em cima
do computador então o áudio que vocês
devem est ouvindo
é do microfone sem fio que tá ligado ao
iPhone e o vídeo que vocês estão vendo é
da câmera do iPhone Então queria saber
se tá bom o áudio se tá claro se tá com
volume suficiente Marta que está ao vivo
por favor me D esse feedback antes gente
continuar pessoal que tá aqui no grupo
do canal fechado vamos entrando Stela
Mares boa noite tá me ouvindo bem
esta Ótimo então isso quer dizer o que
aqui o microfone sem fio ligado ao
iPhone está mandando o áudio para o
computador legal bacana áudio excelente
Obrigado
Eliseu Então vamos lá vamos responder as
dúvidas de vocês depois a gente parte
pro artigu inho
né primeira dúvida pera aí deixa eu
dividir a tela com vocês Né
tava está aqui
aqui e vamos colocar
aqui nessa
configuração eu acho que é melhor deixa
eu aumentar o
[Música]
tamanho
e colocar na questão
individual
ou colocar no sury mesmo é V colocar no
su
aumentar mais um
pouco
ok vamos para lá então vamos para as
perguntas
ahã não isso aqui não é a primeira
pergunta por que que tá nessa pergunta
aqui estranho não tá diferente
[Música]
do o que eu tinha visto
Pera aí Ah tá deve ser por causa disso
eu tô usando um browser diferente dessa
vez eu não tô entendendo Tá diferente
aqui
a alguém deve ter apagado perguntas aqui
bem eu vou fazer o
seguinte tá fora da ordem do que eu
tinha visto antes eu não sei por Mas
vamos lá Quais são os suplementos que
não devem ser utilizados para por quem
possui alguma patologia autoimune como
Artrite reumatoide e quais indica nesse
caso específico bem falando rapidamente
da doença é uma doença autoimune é uma
doença reumatoide né E ela consiste numa
doença que até desculpa que ataca as
juntas ataca as articulações causa dor
inflamação rigidez né então vocês devem
ter visto já alguém com essa doença nas
mãos os dedos ficam tortos né fica com
rigidez
matinal muitas pessoas buscam
suplementos obviamente para tratar esses
sintomas e tem alguns suplementos que
podem atrapalhar em algumas
circunstâncias
Apesar de que não é tão claro essa lista
específica de suplementos que devam ser
evitados mas aí eu fiz uma pesquisa e
que que eu identifiquei alguns produtos
que podem aumentar aosta imune alguns
tipos de suplos baseado de ervas que
poss estimular a produção de cinas Então
tem que tomar cuidado não que
necessariamente ess suplementos vão
causar problemas
tá então alguns óleos essenciais
pode acontecer dele estimular o sistema
imune Então tem que ser testado um a
um para ver se vai ter esse problema de
interferir com a medicação prescrita
eventualmente por um médico mais
ortodoxo Mas entre os suplementos
naturais entre os fitoterápicos tome
cuidado com a equinas porque equinas
estimula o sistema de defesa geralmente
ele vai equilibrar e não vai aumentar
muito mas tem que tomar cuidado isso
pode ser muito individual Então equin
pode pot espmente agravar a atividade da
doença autoimune o
ginz ele pode modular a função
imunológica de uma maneira imprevisível
tanto aumentando quanto diminuindo então
tomar cuidado com o
gizenga a em excesso altas doses dessa
vitamina pode interferir na regulação
imunológica a Ach Ganda né achaga tem
propriedades adaptogênico ela baixa o
cortisol porém ela pode estimular o
sistema imunológico de uma maneira não
Prev
em pacientes com autoimunidade não quer
dizer que todo mundo que tem doença
autoimune Tem que evitar a ch Ganda tá
isso tem que ser visto caso a caso
suplementos de Ferro em excesso pode
acontecer de aumentar o estresse
oxidativo e aumentar a inflamação agora
vamos falar do outro lado da moeda os
suplementos mais indicados e mais
utilizados para quem tem artrite
reumatóide própria vitamina D de dado em
altas doses né porque tem um efeito
imunossupressor Se você usar em doses
altas como no protocolo Coimbra com
todos aqueles cuidados que a gente fala
de evitar alimentos ricos em cálcio
tomar muita água tomar magnésio usar o
própolis né o
ômega-3 também bem interessante pelo
efeito
antiinflamatório glucosamina e
condroitina também são muito utilizados
para ar reumatoide usado para
articulações em geral problemas
articulares em geral a cúrcuma que vocês
estão cansados de saber a curcumina
extraída da cúrcuma pelas propriedades
antiinflamatórias antioxidantes o do o
colágeno hidrolizado Tipo dois também é
muito utilizado e o msm que metil
sulfonil metano também tem atividade
antiinflamatória tem lives no canal
falando sobre todos esses suplementos
lives e vídeos também gravados Ok
obviamente tem que ter uma Tem que
manter um estilo de vida saudável dieta
equilibrada exercícios regulares evitar
o estresse tudo aquilo que eles estão
cansados de saber que eu sempre falo
aqui no canal Ok e acompanhamento médico
nutricional é sempre muito
importante a próxima pergunta que não
sei porque que ficou fora de ordem aqui
qual seria a fórmula do magnésio
inositol para mandarmos manipular e a
posologia deixa eu ver aqui ó acho que
tá aqui em cima essa
pergunta tá tá mais ou menos aqui tá
então vou deixar aqui ó Qual é a
fórmula bem vamos lá ah o magnésio vocês
conhecem bem o mineral que tá envolvido
em mais de 400 atividades no organismo
400 atividades enzimáticas é fundamental
por um monte de
coisa e o inositol É também um elemento
que é considerado hoje uma vitamina do
Complexo B né é uma substância natural
ela é produzido pelo corpo parte da
glicose então a fórmula do magnésio
inositol pode variar dependendo do
produto que está no mercado uma
combinação muito comum é o magnésio
bisglicinato ou glicina na faixa de 200
a 400 mg por dose o inositol entre um a
2 g Isso é uma forma mais comum essa
combinação ela é frequentemente
utilizada para dar suporte à saúde
reprodutiva especialmente em caso de
cindo do ovário policístico e também
para ajudar na regulação do sistema
nervoso central e qual que é a dose a
dose pode variar muito tá é bem comum
você ver aí dos de 1 a 2 g por dia
geralmente dividido em duas doses ou até
três doses mas pode ser tomado só à
noite na hora de deitar
também E aí quando você for utilizar o
magnésio com inositol escolha o magnésio
bisglicinato né junto com o inositol
essa a fómula que você vai encontrar com
mais facilidade magnésio bisglicinato
junto com o
inositol no caso inositol pessoas que TM
transtorno bipolar deve evitar o uso
dele Porque existe uma suspeita que pode
piorar né esses casos aí de
bipolaridade Então a próxima pergunta é
ser o magnésio inositol poderia
substituir o blend magnésio treonato
mais arato e dimalato depende tá eu n eu
não substituiria o que que eu faria eu
faria esse blend de magnésio treonato
aspartato de malato e colocaria no osit
no meio
né Não vejo porque
substituir por quê Porque tem vantagens
né nas formas diferentes de
magnésio então o magnésio tronado você
sabe que atravessa a barreira
hematoencefálica ou
licórnio
memória qualquer doença neurológica o
aspartato geralmente é mais utilizado
nos esportes para aumentar a performance
física então ele é opcional poderia até
deixar ele de Fora em algumas situações
o de Malá sabe que ele tá associado ao
ácido málico aí ele vai entrar dentro da
mitocôndria com mais facilidade É bem
interessante especialmente para coração
então ele vai ajudar na produção de
energia vai ter uma ação
antiinflamatória e vai ser muito útil em
caso de fadiga crônica o inositol já
explicamos aqui vai ter mais benefícios
porque é como se você tivesse utilizando
uma vitamina do Complexo B junto com
magnésio então se você puser usar o
treon o dimalato o glicina mais o
inositol é interessante e opcionalmente
o aspartato né então três ou ou quatro
formas de magnésio junto com o inositol
Então seria uma boa
combinação fe aqui na live passada
perguntei sobre valores de hormônios em
homem eu falei que varia muito de
laboratório para laboratório aí ele
colocou 69 anos que deve ser a idade da
pessoa que tá perguntando entendi sobre
a dificuldade deis
os valores ideais Porém não ficou Claro
para mim quais são os exames que devem
ser feitos deixa eu ver se tá aqui na
tela eu não sei porque saiu da ordem
isso
aqui gente eu vou desencanar esse
negócio de mostrar na tela tá eu vou
seguir a sequência que eu coloquei
aqui bem pessoal O que que você vai
pedir para um homem com 69 anos em
termos de hormônio não é muito diferente
para um cara de 40 anos ou de 50 anos ou
de 80 anos ter estrutura total
testosterona livre
shbg em relação aos hormônios
tiroidianos T3 livre T4 livre hoje eu
não impeço mais T3 Total t4 total Mas
pode pedir o TSH o estradiol o FSH e o
LH Ok então esses são os hormônios que a
gente pode pedir são os mais importantes
para homem dessa idade mas de qualquer
idade na verdade isso aí não é uma coisa
que vai variar muito porque o cara tem
69 ou 40 80 anos de idade
Beleza então a próxima pergunta diz ser
que o consumo elevado de Açúcar
acidifica o sangue e Por conseguinte
aumenta a propensão ao câncer Qual a sua
opinião sim o consumo elevado de Açúcar
ele pode contribuir para a acidificação
Só que não é bem do sangue tá isso É
Complicado explicar o sangue ele vai
manter o PH El não vai acidificar como
eu já expliquei na Live anterior porque
se isso acontecer o cara vai parar na
UTI o organismo consegue compensar isso
ele só não faz isso quando você tá muito
mal mesmo Você tá só o pó da rabiola
morrendo na UTI Ok então mas o que
acontece quando você tem o açúcar em
excesso ele vai ser metabolizado pela
célula e se essa pessoa tiver uma
disfunção
mitocondrial o processo pelo qual a
glicos mas ser quebrado vai predominar
glicólise anaeróbica que produz né é um
processo que é uma fermentação e produz
ácido láctico tá esse ácido láctico vai
acumular na célula e a célula vai
expulsar o ácido láctico para as
redondezas da célula pro espaço
extracelular aí vai começar a ter acidez
mas não é no sangue o pessoal tem
dificuldade de entender isso tem que
estudar a acidez que vai acontecer é no
espaço extracelular no início Ok e se
tiver muito ácio em volta da célula isso
pode até aumentar a chance de a pessoa
ter um câncer
e esse ao no espaço extracelular no
exício pode sobrecarregar o mecanismo de
regulação do PH sanguínio Então vai
acabar puxando magnésio do osso e cálcio
de osso para tentar compensar isso
Beleza então essa história de sangue
ácido esqueçam isso não é sangue que
fica ácido mas eu vou não ficar entrando
muito nesses detalhes porque as pessoas
T dificuldade de entender são vários
compartimentos no organismo tem o
intracelular o extracelular tem o sangue
tem os vários líquidos né Por exemplo
líc cor urina E por aí vai então isso
daí é uma simplificação grosseira tosca
do que acontece essa história de falar
que acidifica o sangue tá eu não gosto
muito dessa conversa tá mas obviamente
para você não sobrecargar o sistema de
tamponamento o sistema tampão que vai
exigir do osso é muito importante você
ter um estilo de vida saudável tomar
bastante água comer alimentos que vão
contrabalançar essa acidificação do
açúcar tá o que que vai mais acidificar
eh não o sangue acidificar Vamos colocar
dessa maneira tá carne processada bida
alcoólica então é importante você
colocar alimentos alcalinos na dieta
como frutas legumes verduras grão
integral tá então você vai dar uma
equilibrada melhor e não vai
sobrecarregar o osso
Ok Doutor quanto ao uso de azul de
metileno Há alguma perda de eficácia a
utilizar em conjunto com antioxidantes
vitamina C A falip poico entre outros
apesar de ser comum a urina sair azulada
o uso concomitante com antioxidantes
pode acabar atenuando essa
característica deixando o azul mais
translúcido uso de cápsulas gastr
resistentes potencializa absorção não
vejo problema nenhum de se associar azul
de metileno com antioxidantes Ok porque
o azul de metileno é um antioxidantes tá
é um antioxidante Então não vai perder
eficácia se você associar vitamina C al
falip poico com o azul de metileno na Na
verdade essa combinação de antioxidantes
vai ajudar vai potencializar os efeitos
benéficos do azul metileno porque aí vão
ser vários antioxidante se
complementando ajudando um ao outro né
então o uso de azul de metileno vai
deixar sua urina azul ou
verde porque o rim vai excretar esse
corante na urina e a combinação com
antioxidante não vai atenuar essa
característica de deixar a urina
colorida ok aens
da cor Depende de várias coisas depende
da quantidade de líquido que você bebe
da sua atividade física e da dosagem Ok
o uso de cásas gastrorresistentes é
interessante porque ele vai ajudar a
potencializar a absorção do azul de
metileno no intestino delgado porque
essas cápsulas são projetadas para
liberar no Delgado onde a absorção do
azul metileno é mais eficiente Ok Isso
não é obrigatório mas ajuda Ok então
isso pode também aumentar a
biodisponibilidade do azul de metilen
Apesar de eu achar que is não é tão
relevante é só se aumentar um pouquinho
a dose do a metileno que isso já vai ser
contrabalançado mas é uma estrateg
interessante Então tem que ver o preço
dessa cápsula gasto resistente Se vai
compensar porque azul de metilene S é um
suplemento barato próximo quais
suplementos auxiliam na Baixa do
cortisol tem vários adaptógenos que
podem ajudar nisso só que eles atuam na
verdade de uma maneira indireta tá o
cortisol vai cair porque o sistema
nervoso central vai se acalmar esse que
é o ponto que eu quero que vocês
entendam não é que ele vai diretamente
na cortical da adrenal baixar o cortisol
Na verdade é um efeito cerebral Ok o
cortisol nós sabemos que é hormônio de
estresse nem muito alto nem muito baixo
É desejado níveis elevados de cortisol
podem inflamar o organismo
eh mesmo que seja um anti inflamatório
um agente antiinflamatório se ficou
exageradamente aumentado ele pode causar
problemas até de memória quantos níveis
baixos vai deixar a pessoa derrubada sem
energia então nem nem é muito alto nem
muito baixo é interessante e quais são
os suplementos os mais usados é fosfati
diuc serina o Ach Ganda que nós
comentamos agora a pouco em outra
pergunta o gaba né porque ele tem ação
direta no cérebro o ácido Gama
aminobutírico né que é o nome completo
do gaba é um neurotransmissor calmante
Então quando você ingere gaba parte dele
vai continuar sendo Gaba e vai ajudar a
acalmar o cérebro a LT anina que é uso
demais que é aminoácido encontrado em
folhas do chá da planta camelia censes
tem efeito calmante muito interessante D
uma calma focada as vitaminas do
complexo B o próprio inositol que nós
falamos também vai
ajudar importante lembrar dos hábitos de
vida saudável yoga meditação
gerenciamento do estresse mindfulness é
muito importante
eh próxima pergunta conheço uma pessoa
que depois que se expõe a luz solar por
alguns minutos começa a ficar com a pele
dolorida desde que essa pessoa passou a
tomar suplemento de vitamina D3 ela pode
se expor ao sol à vontade porque a pele
nunca dói mas se ela para de tomar
vitamina D3 a pele volta a doer quando
ela se expõe ao sol essa pessoa não sabe
que doença é essa mas eu já percebi que
se trata de uma doença autoimune Você
tem alguma ideia de que doença Pode ser
então parece que é um lupus elit Tom
atoso sistêmico porque o lupus é uma
doença autoimune que tem essa esse
efeito de dar fotossensibilidade ela
pode afetar vários órgãos pele
articulações rins pulmões sistema
digestivo sistema nervoso porém ela
prevalece na pele Ok e a vitamina D como
vocês sabem em altas doses é um agente
que pode suprimir doenças autoimunes que
pode ter um efeito imunossupressor em
altas doses e em doses normais entre aç
e vitamina D é imunomoduladora
OK então ela deve procurar o médico para
fazer o diagnóstico Mas provavelmente é
um
lupus eritematoso sistêmico pode ser um
lupus discoide também que são formas de
doença autoimune que afetam a pele e
causa essas lesões avermelhadas e
fotossensibilidade né que é quando você
Tem reações excessivas à luz solar
beleza próxima pergunta estudo
científico comprova gengibre reduz
pressão arterial revisão sistemática e
metanálise envolvendo sete ensaios
clínicos randomizados demonstrou que o
gengibre reduz a pressão eu já falo isso
há muito tempo né nas redes sociais
porque as pessoas sempre perguntam
Gengibre aumenta a pressão arterial eu
sempre respondi que não né Dr Victor
Sorrentino postou essa frase no Face
quem tem pressão baixa tem alguma chance
de tomar sim pode tomar tomando cuidado
né tem que ver isso é individual tem
gente que vai tomar um chá de gengibre
vai ter uma queda acentuada da pressão
vai ficar tonto né especialmente quem
tem pressão baixa demais mas isso é
individual tá eu não acho que vocêo vai
ser uma coisa muito comum que a maioria
das pessoas vão conseguir tomar um gengi
mesmo que tenha pressão baixa Ok e se
tem pressão baixa de mais também aumenta
o consumo de sal integral
Ok e aumenta a sua atividade física né
porque você aumentando a massa muscular
aí a a pressão lateral tende a a
equilibrar mais
ok Lembrando que o gip tem ação
antiinflamatória antioxidante ajuda a
dilatar os vasos por isso que tem essa
ação de baixa pressão arterial e tem
contraindicações o jipe pode interagir
com medicamentos para pressão mas nesse
caso eu prefiro tirar o remédio para
pressão do que o gengibre né faz muito
mais sentido para mim mas o gengibre
também tem efeito anticoagulante então
tomar cuidado quem toma anticoagulante
não utilizar o gengibre junto ok e quem
tá tomando remédio para diabetes também
tem que baixar o remédio do diabetes que
o gengibre Pode baixar o açúcar do
sangue e se você consumir gengive demais
você vai ter dor de estômago vai ter
queimação vai ter enjoo Ok pode ter
diarreia também
indigestão Qual é a dose de TCM para
prevenção de Alzheimer Quais são as
marcas confiáveis não tem uma dose assim
estabeleci na literatura não mas você
pode começar com uma colher de sobremesa
E aí aos poucos até chegar uma colher de
sopa infelizmente os estudos atuais
sobre uso de TCM ou MCT para alsheimer
não estão definindo ainda essa dose
porque são estudos limitados Ok vai
aumentando gradualmente porque você pode
acontecer no começo é você tem uma
diarreia n porque você não tá acostumado
com a gordura do do TCM Ok macas boas
macas recomendadas no Brasil equaliv
essentia internacional n foods nous
Bounty e tem o geral tá são macas aí que
a gente pode recomendar placas de
ateroma nas carótidas tem reversão O que
usar e o que evitar tem reversão sim se
você perguntar isso para médico ortodoxo
você vai te falar para usar estatinas
porque as estatinas Teoricamente
poderiam reverter a aterosclerose
lembrando que a aterosclerose é o
acúmulo de gordura e cálcio nas paredes
das artérias isso vai reduzindo o espaço
que o sangue corre e vai estreitando a
artéria e pode causar AVC isquêmico pode
causar infarto do miocárdio tá são as
duas doenças mais comuns associad a
aterosclerose E aí tem também estudos
mostrando que se você usar natoquinase
por um ano você pode ter redução da
espessura das artérias então você pode
usar dose baixa de statina que é uma
coisa que eu tenho feito muito
consultório e não tem me arrependido
porque não dá efeito colateral e dá o
efeito antiinflamatório da estat que
existe e você pode usar em Associação
natoquinase e pode usar picnogenol pode
usar lumbrokinase pode usar Serra
peptase o estudo que eu conheço que fala
mais sobre isso é um estudo com cerca de
1000 participantes que receberam
natoquinase pela boca por 12 meses e
houve sim uma redução significativa da
espessura da camada íntima e da camada
média da artéria nesse caso foi estudada
a artéria carótida E então houve melhora
do fluxo e melhora do lume dessa artéria
Ok Esse estudo foi interessante porque
ele indicou que a natoquinase foi mais
eficaz em pessoas que fumavam bebiam
álcool tinha um índice de massa corporal
mais
alto e tem outros estudos também que
falam que a natoquinase ajuda a reduzir
a formação de trombos e melhorar a saúde
cardiovascular então eu faria uso de
statina de baixa dosage natoquinase e
picnogenol e pode utilizar outros
suplementos em conjunto aqueles elentos
que aumentam por exemplo o óxido nítrico
como é o caso da citrulina é o caso da
lanina é o caso da norvaline é o caso do
S7 tem vários aí que podem ajudar
Ok Lembrando que a dieta saudável é
fundamental nisso também a atividade
física e a perda de peso além de cortar
o cigarro e o consumo excessivo de
álcool beleza
próxima pergunta qual é a dosagem do
magnésio no citol para auxiliar na
insônia Eu já falei da dosagem né Você
pode tomar de 1 a 2 g à noite mas a
partir de 200 mg eh já vai ter algum
efeito tá então 200 mg pode começar com
essa dose para 500 1 g ou 2 g tomado
antes dormir tá bom são essas doses que
você pode estar pensando
obviamente é muito importante ter
hábitos saudáveis de sono é importante
você evitar a cafeína e álcool antes de
dormir ter aquela prática de uma hora
antes de dormir desligar todos os
eletrônicos telas acesas fazer meditação
fazer mindfulness tomar um banho
relaxante ficar num ambiente de sono
tranquilo sem barulho sem calor
excessivo ou frio excessivo né então é
importante tudo isso
eu acho que foi tudo né Deixa eu ver se
faltou alguma coisa aqui porque ficou
fora de
ordem autoimune magn T3 aqui o T3 usado
somente uma vez ao dia poderá acarretar
alguma consequência desejada só vai ter
menos eficiência porque T3 tem minha
vida curta né eu não recomendo tomar mas
se for para esquecer de tomar é melhor
tomar de manhã do que tomar no meio da
tarde tá então não comendo é melhor
tomar em duas tomadas de manhã e um
pouco antes do almoço mas se for
escolher um horário Toma só de manhã mas
eu acho que não é interessante isso não
porque você vai ter um T3 legal de manhã
e à tarde o T3 vai
cair
ã neroma já falei disso Ã Não falei da
azul de metileno quais suplementos
auxilir na Bai já
falei beleza já falei tudo aqui vamos
ver as perguntas ao vivo Já estamos com
quase meia hora de
Live TAM quinha jogou uma pergunta
aqui aqui
pronto o Dr Victor Sorrentino disse que
a verdadeira potência da cúrcuma é o
óleo dela nós já temos um
Brasil em forma de cápsula com esse óleo
tamb quinha Temos vários suplementos eh
no mercado magistral né nessa Mara de
manipulação que são formas
de curcumina de Alto absorção tá então
isso essa questão do óleo aqui não acho
muito relevante não porque tem umas
quatro macas de curcumina de auto
absorção no mercado
Tá e elas têm lá uma uma fórmula de
micronização da cápsula que é muito mais
importante micronização da partícula da
comida que é muito mais importante se tá
em óleo ou não
hã no desenho da injeção que você
mostrou doses de ozônio vi que a 50 dos
virucida aplicar dos 50 paciente também
terá os benefícios não não é assim
Eliseu não vai não vai empilhando os
benefícios não são faixas diferentes de
ação então a dose virucida não vai ser
uma uma a mesma dose que vai ser
antioxidante ou que que vai ser
antiinflamatória não sei dizer lz eu
deficiência de magnésio Por que que
agora a deficiência de magnésio tá tão
mais comum do que era há 5 anos atrás
não acho isso faça muito sentido não
tá Lógico que deficit de magnésio pode
ser um fator para arritmia cardíaca
assim como deficiência de potássio ou
excesso de potássio ou excesso de magn
magio o excesso de cálcio tem vários
minerais que interferem na arritmia
cardíaca num embalagem de caixo de ovos
caipiras orgânicos diz que um dos
alimentos digeridos pelas galinhas é o
milho eu já não respondi isso semana
passada Eliseu respondi isso eu não tava
né porém todo milho no Brasil é
transgênico nem todo milho no Brasil é
transgênico a grande maioria é tá esses
ovos são confiáveis não eu eu confiaria
no ovo que a galinha a maior parte da
alimentação dela é de ciscar no chão
tá a deficiência magnésio não provocaria
morte súbita Sim já respondi isso sim
mas por que que você acha que o magnésio
tá mais deficiência
agora não acho que isso seja o fator
principal não
tá perguntou sim Eliseu é porque você
não entrou na Live da semana passada eu
tinha falado sobre isso
Mas não tem
problema Bem pessoal vamos discutir aqui
o o o artigo do José
n bem esse tema é muito relevante muito
urgente é sobre as implicações das
terapias gênicas e os efeitos da
proteína Spike no sistema nervoso
central tá com avanço né dos últimos
estudos de 2022 para cá principalmente
em relação à aquela moléstia que vocês
conhecem temos observado o qu um aumento
significativo de complicações
neurológicas que estão sendo debatidas
por diversos especialistas então Vamos
explorar esse assunto com base em
informações robustas
e especialmente aí nos baseando
nesse assunto que o Dr José n abordou na
palestra dele durante a o congresso
médicos pela
vida então vocês sabem Dr juden é uma
figura renomada no campo da neurociência
e neurocirurgia el tem um currículo
muito extenso muito impressionante que
tem atuação em universidades de destaque
como a Columbia University ele tem uma
experiência valiosa em áreas como
neuromodulação cirurgia e doenças
neurodegenerativas e
se preocupou muito né com a condição aí
do de 2020 e foi uma figura de destaque
que você sabe muito bem então durante a
apresentação o Dr naser enfatizou como
as terapias gênicas você sabe do que eu
tô falando introduzidas durante os
eventos de 2020 foram gerando
preocupações devido à falta de controle
eh porque não foi terminados os estudos
das técnicas experimentais né a fase
três não foi
concluída e o impacto a longo prazo
dessas terapias então a questão central
aqui é se e até que ponto Essas
tecnologias que incluem a produção de
proteínas de Sparks induzidas né pelas
células do nosso corpo que eles falam
que é só um deltoide mas não é a gente
já sabe que esse negócio espalha para
tudo quanto é lado se essa Protein Spark
poderia ou não causar danos
irreversíveis ao nosso sistema
nervoso Então vamos falar um pouquinho
sobre o papel da Protein Spike no
cérebro ela é altamente tóxica ela tem
uma afinidade perigosa pelo sistema
nervoso central estudos mostram que essa
proteína uma vez que tá dentro do
cérebro ela pode causar inflamações e
Danos neurológicos levando a condições
como encefalopatias doenças
degenerativas e até agravamento eu vi
isso daí viu com paciente meu
agravamento de Quadros
como paxon e Alzheimer então a
preocupação maior segundo ncer é que
essa proteína poderia ter a capacidade
de atravessar as barreiras importantes
como é o caso da barreira
hematoencefálica ou hicória
afetando o funcionamento normal do nosso
cérebro essa descoberta levanta uma
bandeira vermelha em relação às terapias
gênicas utilizando o RNA
mensageiro porque nós temos uma produção
Descontrolada
dessa proteína em excesso da proteína s
ou Spike que pode estar associado ao
surgimento de doenças neurológicas
graves ou agravamento como eu vi de
maneira muito trágica numa paciente
minha que tava indo bem e depois de
né acabou deteriorando muito rapidamente
então Dr ncer Alerta que a comunidade
científica está apenas começando a
compreender a magnitude desse
problema e vocês sabem eu publiquei um
vídeo recente que eu me expus muito eu
não falei nome de nada mas eu mostrei
uma seringa durante o vídeo e já
apareceu um haer lá falando que era
covardia eu estar falando né dessas
terapias gênicas porque existia AVC
antes né da dos eventos de 2020 né É
ridículo né esse argumento Mas eu
respeito eu tenho até compaixão por essa
pessoa só espero que ela não tenha feito
uma denúncia pro YouTube ficar
continuando me perseguindo né mas
continuando no
artigo Outro ponto crítico levantado foi
a relação entre a proteína Spike e as
chamadas proteínas priônicas o que que é
o prion é uma proteína que consegue se
replicar tá é uma proteína defeituosa
que se dobra de maneira errada e se
multiplica e começa a acumular no
organismo e começa a bagunçar todo o
Coreto digamos assim especialmente
começa a bagunçar os neurônios e
atrapalhar comunicação entre os
neurônios né então a doença de cidf
Jacob cidf Jacob é a principal doença
priônica que graças a Deus é Rara mas
que dá aquela doença da vaca louca que
talvez você tenha ouvido
falar mas o ponto interessante é que o
Alzheimer que tem aquele problema das
proteínas mal formadas que é a betam
Milo também a proteína Natal tem
características também que lembram a
questão ônica Ok então segundo torná a
evidência de que a proteína Spike pode
desencadear processos que envolvam o
acúmulo de proteínas mal dobradas no
cérebro como é o Cao do Alzheimer
acelerando o desenvolvimento dessas
doenças neurodegenerativas como Pax
alheimer Então isso é especialmente
alarmante considerando que muitas
pessoas que receberam as terapias
gênicas estão apresentando sintomas
neurológicos muitas pessoas que têm a
síndrome longa né está tendo problemas
aí de bem fog né de nerva mental então o
Dr nas destacou que essas proteínas mal
formadas mal dobradas podem se comportar
de maneira infecciosa se
autorreplicar pelo sistema nervoso
central e levando a degeneração
progressiva das funções cerebrais então
isso reforça a necessidade de mais
estudos e transparência sobre os efeitos
dessas terapias experimentais a longo
prazo um dos pontos mais preocupantes
discutidos durante o evento foi o
impacto das terapias gênicas em crianças
e gestantes o Dr ncia mencionou dados
alarmantes sobre o aumento de doença
neurológica e deformidade em
recém-nascidos cujas mães receberam
essas terapias gênicas durante a
gravidez então a evidência segundo ele é
Clara os riscos são altos e não podem
ser ignorados ele destaca também o
trabalho de outros especialistas como Dr
James thorp ou Thor se você quiser falar
sem a pronúncia americana que estudaram
os efeitos dessas terapias em gestantes
e apontaram para um aumento
significativo de complicações então Dr
ner conclui que para proteger as futuras
gerações é essencial que mais cautela
seja tomada antes de expor as crianças e
grávidas à terapias experimentais então
o impacto neurológico pode ser
devastador com consequências que podem
se manifestar ao longo de toda a vida
finalizando então Dr José n deixa uma
mensagem muito clara e importante
estamos apenas começando a entender os
efeitos das terapias gênicas no sistema
nervoso central o que nós o que nós já
sabemos é muito preocupante que a
proteína s ou proteína Spike desempenha
um papel muito crucial em diversas
doenças neurodegenerativas acelerando e
piorando essas doenças e a exposição a
essa proteína especialmente por meio das
terapias experimentais apresenta muitos
riscos que T que ser amplamente
discutidos sem preconceitos e
sem censura pessoal a recomendação é
muito clara precisamos continuar
investigando os impactos e repensar o
uso das terapias com essa tecnologia do
RNA mensageiro em populações vulneráveis
como crianças e gestantes Ok então essa
mensagem muito importante que eu queria
passar para vocês hoje tá
já temos 38 minutos dúvidas a respeito
dessa apresentação pessoal vamos focar
nisso aqui
agora Eloí Boa noite não precisa pedir
desculpa de novo Eliseu com a história
da luz solar Eliseu Vai tomar o seu
solzinho para de ficar eloc Brando
Eliseu entendeu
ao ir pro quintal de casa me espor a luz
solar se eu ficar de olho fechado mesmo
assim ativo o ciclo seic deando é só
você você não pode olhar diretamente pro
sol você vai machucar a sua retina
né não não fica com olho aberto olhando
pro sol não
Eliseu Não faça
isso não é bem assim não Eliseu ele na
verdade essa história queo adap óo
regula para cima e para baixo também
achava isso anos atrás mas hoje em dia a
gente sabe que não é bem assim tá o que
realmente regula o cisol é isso aqui ó é
acalmar o cérebro tá e a ch Ganda ajuda
a acalmar o cérebro por isso que ela
atua de manhã é bom ter cortisol alto
sim e tem que tá alto de manhã médio de
tarde baixo de noite tá ao tomar a ch
Ganda de manhã o cortisol baixa
Não na verdade não vai desregular a
ponto de de causar problema não tá
seessa que é a sua
dúvida você quê que a terceira fase não
comprida foi proposital eu acho que foi
proposital no sentido de que não deu
tempo né teria que passar mais de 2 anos
ou 3 anos para completar isso E também
porque eles queriam que não completasse
para poder não aparecer com muita
clareza os problemas dessa tecnologia tá
Então são duas respostas que eu dei
paraa sua
pergunta quais marcas de cúrcuma no
Brasil tem nos Estados Unidos Meriva
eh que é uma marca muito boa Qual que é
a outra mesmo
é me fugiu agora Meriva é uma outra
é esqueci agora mas no Brasil eu uso
muito curcuvail tá ccu vail que é da
manipulação
Já percebi que T do Coimbra entende que
o suplemento que K2 não funciona como
deveria ingerir altas doses de T3 Não
entendi essa colocação sua não esse
altas dose seria a partir de quanto
seria a partir de 50.000 unidades por
dia que é a dose para imunossupressão tá
50.000 unidades por dia não use nunca
essa dose sem acompanhamento médico
porque essa dose imunos supressora não é
imunomoduladora
dela para cima né 50.000 para cima acha
melhor evitar o uso de espirulina
clorela e alga kelps não não acho que
Deva evitar esses daí não
tá não tem essa correlação Que eu saiba
não Eliseu a dose de pqq de 10 a 20 MG
por dia mas eu acho que pode tomar
tranquilamente 40 também que não vai dar
problema mas eu não conheço essa
correlação não existe que eu sabe estudo
falando que tem que ser uma proporção
entre um e o outro não se tiver eu não
conheço depois eu posso dar uma olhada É
verdade que idoso come menos devido à
pouca quantidade de ácido clorídrico sim
indiretamente o idoso sente desconforto
gastando come muito e acaba comendo
menos tá o desconforto é por causa da
deficiência de ácio clorídrico
por qual motivo o idoso tem mudança do
paladar porque envelheceu
Eliseu K2 não leva o Calcio pros ossos
na quantidade suficiente Quando se usa
fta as doses D3 Sim é lógico é lógico né
não vai conseguir compensar
totalmente de nada de nada
Marta mais perguntas pessoal Eliseu
Esquece essa história de sol vai vai
tomar o solzinho de manhã cedo fecha o
olho não olha pro sol sen vai machucar
sua retina para com essas firula aí de
ah se eu tiver no sol e tiver nublado e
for lua cheia e o o avião passar no céu
não sei o que lá para de elocubrar rapaz
faz a coisa simplifica não complica as
coisas entendeu falo para você de
coração isso aí sem querer ser ser chato
entendeu mais perguntas pessoal
sobre autismo tem vídeos no canal Eu não
falo muito sobre esse assunto
José quem que fala muito de
autismo talvez a Poliana Castro Mas eu
nem sei se ela ter canal no YouTube Tom
clorídrico a 25% qu pingos é suficiente
para digestão eu começaria com dois tá
dilui na água Vai devagar com isso daí
Porque é muito potente esse produto tá é
muito potente
acho que tá bom né pessoal encerrar
né eu vou esperar mais um minuto tá até
porque a bateria do iPhone tá caindo
aqui e ele que tá servindo de câmera
né sim ativa o ciclo C cardiano sim tá
Eliseu não tem que ficar com ol aberto
não tá porque na verdade você vai mesmo
com olho aberto vai passar Luz pela
pálpebra né então não não fica com essa
preocupação não tá e cuidado para não
olhar pro
sol sim pode elía mas todos os meus
pacientes que eu tô eh conversando né
trocando ideia se quer usar EV mectina
por longos períodos eu tô fazendo
assinar um termo de consentimento
informado porque se essa pessoa tropeçar
na rua Vai ser culpa da i mectina e Vão
pôr na minha conta entendeu então isso é
muito complicado porque não tem estudo
Clínico tem estudo em vitro em vivo eu
acredito que ela funciona mas eu preciso
de um tempo de consentimento informado
porque isso daí é muito incipiente ainda
tá obrigado Tami quinha Obrigado
Eliane vamos encerrar por aqui até a
próxima pessoal